Existe toxicidade se o metfolato estiver
acima do valor de referência? Olha só,
pessoal, hoje vamos bater um papo sobre
uma questão que tem aparecido muito no
consultório e que pode estar acontecendo
com você também, a vitamina B9, o ácido
fólico e tá nas alturas, aí bate aquela
preocupação, né? Será que isso é
perigoso? Então vem comigo que eu vou
explicar tudinho de um jeito que você
não vai deixar de entender, vai entender
perfeitamente. Imagina que o medifolato
é tipo aquele tempero especial da vovó.
Você precisa dele pra receita ficar boa,
mas se você exagerar na mão, pode
estragar tudo. O medifolato é a forma
ativa da vitamina B9, aquele folato que
a gente tanto ouve falar. É como se
fosse a versão turbinada, pronta para
usar, que nosso corpo consegue
aproveitar direto, sem precisar fazer
aquela conversão complicada. Agora vamos
ao que interessa. Quando falamos de
valores de referência, a coisa fica
interessante. Diferente do ácido fólico
comum, que tem um limite estabelecido de
1000 mg por dia, o metilfolato é um
bicho diferente. Estudos mostram que
doses de até 15 mg por dia, olha só,
isso é 15 vezes mais que o limite do
ácido fólico comum. São geralmente
seguras essas doses e bem toleradas. Mas
calma lá, isso não significa que você
pode sair tomando etifolato como se
fosse água, não. O lance é o seguinte,
nosso corpo tem os seus mecanismos de
proteção natural, tipo aqueles alarmes
de casa. Quando você toma ácido fólico
comum, ele passa por várias etapas de
conversão e seu corpo consegue controlar
direitinho quanto vai usar. Já o
metiofolato, meu amigo, ele pula essas
etapas todas. É como entrar pela porta
dos fundos direto na cozinha. Por isso
que às vezes a coisa pode desandar.
Deixa te contar uma história real que
ilustra bem isso. Uma paciente de 61
anos estava há 20 anos sem nenhuma crise
de psoriase. Aí descobriu que tinha uma
mutação no GNMT HFR e começou a tomar 15
mg de metifolato por dia. Em poucos
dias, tcharã, a psorias voltou com tudo.
É como se o corpo dela tivesse dito:
"Opa, pera aí, isso tá demais para mim".
E os sintomas de excesso, rapaz, isso é
uma lista que você precisa ficar
esperto. Tem gente que começa a sentir
uma irritabilidade do nada, tipo quando
você tá no trânsito e qualquer coisinha
já tá ficando nervoso. Outros relatam
insônia, aquela sensação de estar ligado
um 220 o tempo todo, dor muscular, dor
nas juntas, confusão mental, é como se
seu corpo entrasse em overdrive. OK? O
mais curioso é que tem gente que se
sente maravilhoso na primeira semana.
Energia lá em cima, memória fiada, humor
nas alturas. Aí na segunda semana, bum,
os sintomas desagradáveis
aparecem.
É tipo quando você exagera no café, no
começo é tudo lindo, depois vem a
tremedeira e ansiedade. Tem um detalhe
que descobri pesquisando. Pessoas com
certas condições, como a disfunção do
eixo hipófise adrenal, a antiga fadiga
adrenal, são especialmente sensíveis ao
mitifolato. É como ter alergia a
camarão. Para alguns não faz nada, para
outros é um problemão. E olha que
interessante, tem gente que reage mal
até com doses pequenininhas. enquanto
outros toleram doses maiores, uma boa. A
questão da metilação é fundamental aqui.
Pensa assim, a metilação é como sistema
de reciclagem do seu corpo. Quando você
tomafolato demais, é como jogar material
demais na reciclagem de uma vez só e o
sistema pode ficar sobrecarregado. Isso
afeta a produção de neurotransmissores,
aqueles mensageiros químicos do corpo,
do nosso cérebro. E aí que a coisa
complica. Uma coisa que poucos sabem, o
metifolato não acumula no corpo do mesmo
jeito que outras vitaminas. O excesso
geralmente é eliminado pela urina, mas o
problema não é o acúmulo em si, é o
efeito imediato de terfolato demais
circulando de uma vez. É como a
diferença entre beber água devagar
durante o dia e tentar tomar 2 L de uma
vez. Para quem tem a mutação MTH FR, a
situação ainda mais delicada. Se as
pessoas já têm dificuldade para
converter o ácido fólico comum, então
tifolato parece solução perfeita, mas aí
que tá. Começar com doses altas pode ser
como dar um banho de água gelada em quem
já tá com febre. O choque pode ser forte
demais. Agora, como evitar problemas?
Primeiro, nunca, mas nunca mesmo, comece
a tomar metifolato por conta própria, só
porque o exame deu alterado. Cada
organismo é único e o que funciona pro
seu vizinho pode não funcionar para
você. Segundo, se você já toma e começou
a sentir sintomas estranhos, não
insista. O seu corpo tá tentando te
avisar alguma coisa. O ideal é começar
com doses baixinhas, tipo 400 a 800
microg e aumentando aos poucos se
necessário. É como entrar numa piscina
fria, você vai se adaptando devagar e
sempre, sempre mesmo, com acompanhamento
profissional. Tem médicos que recomendam
até fazer pausa no tratamento quando
você tá se sentindo bem, porque mais nem
sempre é melhor. Uma dica de ouro. Se
você começar a sentir efeitos
colaterais, alguns profissionais sugerem
tomar uma dose pequena de neacina, tipo
10 a 50 mg. É como apertar o botão de
reset no sistema, mas olha, isso é
paliativo. O importante é ajustar a dose
ou até parar se for necessário.
Concluindo nossa conversa, metifolato
acima dos valores de referência não é
necessariamente tóxico no sentido
clássico da palavra. Não é como um
veneno que vai te derrubar na hora, mas
pode sim causar um desequilíbrio no seu
sistema que traz sintomas bem
desagradáveis. Em alguns casos pode até
reativar condições que estavam
controladas, como vimos no caso da
pessoriase. E sempre, pessoal, o segredo
está no equilíbrio na personalização do
tratamento e principalmente em ouvir o
que seu corpo está dizendo. Se você tá
tomando o etifolato e tá sentindo ótimo,
maravilha. Se começou a sentir coisas
estranhas, é hora de reavaliar. E se o
exame deu alto, mas você não toma
suplemento, pode ser que sua alimentação
esteja rica em folatas naturais ou que
você tenha uma capacidade aumentada de
produção. Nem sempre isso é um problema.
Lembra, cada corpo é universo único. O
que serve para um pode não servir pro
outro. Por isso, a medicina
personalizada é tão importante. Não é
sobre seguir protocolos inessados, é
sobre encontrar o que funciona
especificamente para você. E isso, meus
amigos, só dá para fazer com
acompanhamento profissional adequado e
muita observação dos sinais que o seu
corpo dá. Compartilhe os vídeos, faça
bem. A vida de alguém pode mudar também
no canal do além do se envolva. Ah.